remarkable story about the band you know
them imagine dragons which has millions
of fans all around the world an
encounter with one fan in their early
years has had such a powerful grip on
them for nearly a decade now
jamie yukas joined the band to learn how
an unforgettable teenager helps spur an
invaluable mission it's part of our
series we call it a more perfect union
which aims to show that what unites us
as americans is far greater than what
divides us
[Music]
before their mega success
imagine dragons was hustling for
recognition in small clubs like la's
viper room
no it's the same i love it
the year was 2012. its time would become
imagine dragon's debut single
[Applause]
[Music]
the lyrics were influenced by dan
reynolds lifelong struggle with
depression and while the song introduced
the band to the world it touched the
very soul of a young fan we were a small
unsigned act there was a boy in the
audience that was a super fan that was
raised on his brother's shoulders who
had no hair because of chemo and was
skin and bones was really in the middle
of cancer that superfan was 16 year old
tyler robinson fighting stage 4 cancer
his brother jesse actually snuck tyler
out of the hospital to take him to see
his favorite band
i told him mom and dad are going to come
down on me hard
so you have to back me up if we're doing
this and he's like i got it i got it
we're doing this we did what we always
did we
stole my dad's car and just went
and listened to music jesse had sent the
group a facebook message asking them to
sing it's time for tyler explaining the
song has been his fighting theme through
chemo
that moment when their heads touch and
they're singing to each other screaming
at the top of their lungs
i'll never forget that moment ever as
long as i live i never felt any emotion
like that even felt incredibly spiritual
and going home it was like an amazing
thing to share with my family and it's
we didn't get in trouble
a friendship was born that night
and as the band began to catch fire dan
would text tyler to share the joy he was
just there to enjoy the music but his
attitude towards life was so inspiring
and i can honestly say from that moment
i have been changed
[Applause]
[Music]
the band dedicated their next single
demons to tyler the video has now been
viewed nearly 1 billion times but in
2013 the cancer returned and attacked
tyler's brain dan called me he had just
gotten some terrible news about tyler
and just was so distraught and we cried
together and
thought that tyler's legacy has to live
on
shortly after his death the band reached
out to tyler's parents about launching
the tyler robinson foundation
its mission helping families bear the
emotional and financial burden of
children fighting cancer i always
thought okay
good people care about their children
great people care about other people's
children that's unbelievable that
someone cares that much
this year's fundraiser in las vegas
brought in more than two and a half
million dollars there's nothing
that
grounds you quicker and reminds you
of what matters than when you see a kid
who is yet to get to experience all the
things that you have that has been given
a cancer diagnosis it's a diagnosis for
the whole family seeing the kids that
that we're able to help and everything
they go through it's the most meaningful
thing that we've been able to do
sorry
i'm appreciating that you're just being
as open as you are with your feelings if
i could hold it back i would
believe me whatever it
takes the non-profit has already
provided support to some 2 thousand
families
including eight-year-old jory bonners
what have they helped you with
rental assistance groceries christmas
it's been a big blessing
the family was on the verge of eviction
because jovi left his job to take his
son for treatments
now this tough little guy
is battling brain cancer again each time
it comes back it's just a little bit
more damaging for us because we know
time is not
on our side
[Music]
for the band the event is always an
emotional night
people have to drive meaning in a lot of
different ways i feel like that's one
thing that we know for a fact
we're making a difference we're doing
something powerful and important we love
you tyler wherever you are thank you for
all that you continue to share with us
you inspire us
reynolds was inspired to pledge a 50 000
donation if a guest was willing to sing
the band's huge hit
[Music]
12 year old cooper sandoval picked up
the mic and brought down the house
50 000 voice right there for cbs
mornings i'm jamie yukas in las vegas
radioactive indeed i've been following
imagine dragons since they first came
out and just when you think you couldn't
love them more there they go i love what
ben mckee said i mean he said if i could
hold it back i would don't hold it back
ben
i see you wrote down the same thing i
wrote down uh good people care about
their own kids yes great great people
care about other people's kids i wrote
that down too because i thought i want
to remember that that's true we should
all remember that that's for sure yeah
what a story all right thank you jamie
that's right